mom if you had eight arms  what would you do with the extra ones  hey i would just show them off and call  myself the spider lady  good answer mom  good night i love you mommy  the doctors couldn't find anything  physically wrong with your son  think you could have been dreaming wake  up honey  why do you think these people were here  who were they  that was raised in a cold it was them  they're coming for us  they awakened something in him  i was dreaming what about  i was drowning in a river of blood  this cult may still be out there  is that the boy  there was never any cult she retreated  into a fantasy world  if this is real she needs our protection  now what if it's not  say the words  it's all in your head  you have no idea  you